when you were in the facility and you
knew the drug tester was there let's say
May or whatever else you were definitely
gonna go by and go you guys today were
you confused like I was when you first
got there though about people being
excited to be drug tested early on like
remember when I met that player in
Oakland I don't know if guys say they
don't say his name
okay but like we were hanging out he was
like I got drug testers oh man that
sucks he was like are you kidding me
he's like no I'm free release you talk
about like the drug program is really
intense it's miserable to call them
before you go anywhere they ask you
while you pee right you can be tested up
to three times a week I believe I mean
it's it's it's I believe ten times a
month they can test you and you're
definitely once a month yeah you're
definitely get once a week and of course
they're gonna throw curve balls at you
in some weeks you might get to two in a
week maybe even three in a week maybe
three days in a row cuz they might go oh
let's see maybe he thinks he's gonna get
it long can we talk about the time you
got caught the second time or is that
two months no it's okay I'm just gonna
say like I never realized that you lost
four games X one year I did I'm being
totally honest here do it alright fine
are you cool with it I'm cool it's fine
I
yeah I one year in in Tampa Bay I was in
the drug program and I took a chance I
did I got home from a preseason game and
the guys were hanging out and I was like
damn and that looks fun and I I took a
few hits and I ended up getting in the
program again yes and I lost four games
did he test like the next day it was it
was a great man I'm busted
but yes you lost four games X because of
that man good thing it was my rookie
contract it was nothing bigger than big
money my question is yes when you know
that you're playing for free yeah
doesn't matter
never factors in not at all but after
the gate like cuz when do you get the
game checks yeah I mean it depends on
the team but you're usually like what
every other game maybe right so like on
a Tuesday so everyone's in the locker
and they're looking at their checks and
you're just like alright nothing
there's no nimble open night I'm still
humble I just still think it's crazy you
guys don't get direct deposit
are you do but you're also gonna get a
piece of paper to go this has been
deposited into your account right
you're gonna have something no matter
what but yeah just real long story short
the drug program miserable you can be
tested all the time they can come to
your house how many times was I on the
way to see a movie with my wife really
and then they call and there I was like
damn honey I mean they wouldn't meet you
at the movie theater no I think we got
to go back like because you have a time
once they call you the time limit starts
let me ask you haven't gone through that
right did it did it make you go I don't
want to do this like I'm gonna like I'm
not gonna do the drugs it's just not
worth it yeah I mean no obviously I did
not learn my lesson completely there I
did not that's just what I am I'm a
little bit stubborn that way how many
does it take to get out of it oh so it
depends on your behavior and if you fail
test when you're in there but once
you're in you're in for basically two
years straight right yeah so you're in
two years straight like you said if I
went home to New Jersey I'd have to call
the NFL League offices and go hey I'm
going to New Jersey I'm gonna be at this
address yeah you can reach me at this
number and they're gonna come get you